welcome to your program 3abn today Bible
Q&A we are very happy to be with you
this following hour my name is I Alia
deny and it's a privilege for me to
welcome you along with our panelist
during this hour and you know when is
Bible Q&A that means it's class time so
grab your bible and have your notebook
or pad ready where to write down the
answers and notes and comments and also
tips that we may be sharing with you
during this hour with us here in the
studio we have Pastor Daniel moriconi
welcome to the program well thank you so
much it's always good to be here amen
amen and we have my very own John deny
welcome thank you it's a blessing to be
here and to study God's word and share
God's word amen you ready for the
program by God's grace you've been
studying a lot and you know praise the
Lord for for these men that are men of
the word of God now we have of course
digitally we have James rafy Pastor rafy
welcome hey good to be here Dalia nice
to join you looking forward to the
blessings of the Q&A amen thank you for
joining us uh praise the Lord for
technology when we use it for the good
it's a great blessing to us and to
everyone around the world you know I
would like to start off with prayer if
you don't mind at I'd like to pray for
you at home and of course for our
panelists as well because it is
wonderful to pray for one another there
are needs and there are distractions in
our lives that s throws at us and
distracts us from the word and yes we do
have questions we have doubts but praise
God there are answers in the live manual
which is the Holy Bible and that is
where we're what we're using to answer
your questions during this hour and
every program that has to do with Bible
Q&A let's pray together father God we
want to thank you so much for your
goodness and your mercy your
faithfulness father we are gathered
around this
table to praise you to lift you high to
uh demonstrate how you have taught us
through the Bible how every question
every doubt can be cleared with through
your word so we ask Lord for those at
home in prison in the hospital wherever
they may find themselves even radio
listeners for you to anoint their ears
and their hearts that whatever issues
they're facing in their lives right now
that will not be a distraction in order
to receive the answers that you're
seeking for so we thank you for your
peace we thank you for your word we
thank you for your men here that are
present to represent you we are
ambassadors of the Kingdom so we pray
father that you will you will use us and
bless everyone who is present in this
class in Jesus name amen amen amen amen
you know I want to share with you at
home also that Proverbs 3 uh
5-7 I really like it it says trust in
the Lord with all your heart and lean
not on your own understanding in all
your ways acknowledge Him and He Shall
direct your paths number seven says do
not be wise in your own eyes
fear the lord and depart from Evil and
you know what and there's also another
promise I can do all things through
Christ who strengthens me so it is in
Jesus name that we launch this class and
before we start with the first question
Pastor rafy I think it's a good idea to
share the contact information because
there are people who have questions and
are just tuning in saying I wanted to
send that question in and they forgot to
so Bible QA 3abn TV is the email Bible
QA
3abn.org
gramers and also we have a phone number
where you can send your comments and
questions and that is 618 228
3975 618 2283
3975 let's launch with the first
question and this is from Leroy who
phoned in his question Pastor refy which
you'll answer who wrote the book of
Hebrews that is a great question you
know there are some differences in
emphasis and writing style and Hebrews
compared to Paul's other Epistles but
there is still good reason to believe
that Paul is actually the writer of
Hebrews and not Timothy as some
theologians believe one of the clearest
I think personal uh emphasis or clearest
reasons is Paul's undying love for the
Hebrews his Kinsman according to the
Flesh and he in despite of his
persecution from the Jews he through
love desired to make this a personal
appeal to the Hebrews by writing this uh
this book it was also very much
something that Paul was able to write
because he had been a Pharisee and he
was very familiar with the economy and
with all of the in the details the
insights that we find in the book of
Hebrews uh but in addition there seems
to be it seems to be more than the
coincidence at least in my understanding
that a number of the in in a number of
the occasions in the book of Hebrews
there's a use of the same illustrations
terminology and reasoning in Paul's
other writings for example in Paul's
letter to the Romans uh he recounts the
history of the Jews which was filled
with
unbelief and he calls the Gentiles to
stand in faith and to fear rather being
than being high-m minded and you can
find that in Romans 11 specifically
verse 20 the same approach in
terminology is found in Hebrews chap 4
veres 1-6 another example is found in
Paul's letter to the Corinthians where
he recounts the history of Israel their
Wilderness wanderings and the history
terminology is almost identical to what
is written in Hebrews 3: 15 to 19 and
again in 1 Corinthians chapter 3 1 and2
Paul refers to Believers as babe in
Christ in need of milk and not meat the
meat of the word and once again we find
this same illustration or terminology
found in Hebrews 5:
12-14 uh and one final example is PA is
seen in Paul when we compare 1
Corinthians 9 with Hebrews chapter 12 in
1 Corinthians 9 he talk Paul talks about
the Christian uh experience as a race he
illustrates it that as a race and he
urges us to to battle against sin and he
does the same thing in Hebrews 12 and
verse one and then there's this this in
this this additional internal evidence
and what do I mean by that well in
Hebrews 12:34 for example Paul talks
about uh having compassion on on me in
my bonds he says well if you look if you
compare that to Philippian 113 and also
to to um filon 17 14 and 16 and
Colossians 4:18 excuse me Phil filon 10
verse 10 because it's only one chapter
there and then Philippians 17
14- 16 Paul uses that same phrase in my
bonds right so it's used in Hebrews it's
used in in uh
Philippians uh Paul in Hebrews 13:23
talks about Timothy as his brother right
and and then he said he us that same
terminology about Timothy in 2
Corinthians 1 verse one Timothy my
brother or our brother and of course in
other places like Colossians and
Thessalonians and then finally Paul in
Hebrews 13:18 he says pray for us we
trust that we will have a good
conscience in all things will need to
live honestly well in 1 Thessalonians
5:25 and in 2 Thessalonians 3:1 Paul
uses the same ter terminology pray for
us pray for us pray for us so so we can
see from the internal evidence as well
as uh illustrations terminology
reasoning found in Paul's other writings
that he is the author of the book of
Hebrews excellent thank you very much
Pastor and thank you Leroy for calling
through aan with your question we're
going to move on to Pastor Moroni and
the question for you uh we receive it
from Lena in the Philippines through
Instagram and her question is when
making important decisions is it okay
for me to say my prayers out loud or
write write them down the enemy might
know it and use it to deceive me how
about regular prayers should I just pray
in my mind Lena wants to know well
that's a really good question Lena thank
you so much for the question and you
know that is a good question you kind of
wonder wow if I pray out loud he's going
to hear me he'll know what I'm going to
be doing and want to do but let me just
give you a couple of examples from the
Bible talks about prayer Jesus in Luke
11:1 it says now Jesus was praying in a
certain place when he finished one of a
disciples said to him Lord teach us to
pray just as John taught his disciples
so more than likely Jesus was praying
out loud there where they could hear him
they could see him of course however his
position was and uh of course definitely
he was pre praying out loud when he did
the Lord's Prayer we call it but Matthew
chapter 6 verse 6 again that's another
version of that same in incident but
thou when thou prayest enter into thy
closet and when thou Hast shut the door
pray to thy father which is in secret
and thy father which seeth in secret
shall reward thee openly but when you
pray use not vain repetitions as the
Heathen do for they think that they
shall be heard for their much speaking
be not therefore like unto them for your
father knoweth what things you have need
of even before you ask him after this
manner therefore pray ye Our Father
which art in heaven Hallowed be thy name
so in this situation here where it says
praying in secret it wasn't so much so
that nobody else would hear hear because
Satan can be wherever too right I mean
he can get in the closet but it was more
that you weren't boasting like they
would a lot of them would do they stand
on the street corner so everybody think
they were really holy or Pious that's
what they were doing so that's what he
was getting
at so you know Satan's had a lot of
experience over the thousands of years
that he's been around and knows pretty
much what we're thinking or are what's
important to us and so forth so far
trying to trick him that way I don't
know that that would make any difference
to you know not pray out loud and when
we do hear ourselves praying we actually
uh reinforces in our own minds what
we're praying for here's a an example
from Nehemiah where he was praying in uh
Nehemiah chapter 1 ver4 and it came to
pass when I heard these words that I sat
down and wept and mourned certain days
and fasted and prayed before the god of
heaven and said I beseech thee O Lord
God Of Heaven the great and terrible God
that keepeth Covenant and mercy for them
that love him and observe his
Commandments and then in chapter 2 verse
4 and 5 we see how he sends up a silent
prayer so it's okay to pray silently too
like he's in front of the king there and
the King notices that he's not real
happy that day so he's asking the king
said unto me for what Dost thou make
request so I prayed to God to the god of
heaven so he silently prayed to the god
of heaven and I said to the king if it
please the king and If thy servant have
found favor in thy sight that thou would
has send me unto Judah unto the city of
give father's my father's suppers that I
may build it so silent or open either
way thank you Pastor and thank you Lena
from the Philippines and using our
Instagram account we're going to move on
to John deny and this question came in
through email so you ready here it goes
how do you get three days and three
nights from the traditional teaching
that the crucifixion of Jesus took place
on Friday and the resurrection took
place on Sunday thank you very much for
that question you may remember in
Genesis chapter one The Bible
establishes that a day is composed of
the night portion and the day portion so
that equals one day so the question is
how do you get three days and three
nights some people want to find exactly
three days and three nights in this
equal equal to 72 hours but that that is
not necessarily the case according to
the Jewish way of Reckoning and please
remember that the Bible writers wrote
according to the custom of the day they
didn't know the Customs coming up in a
100 years 500 years how people would
count time so they counted uh what we
would call today or it's called
inclusive Reckoning inclusive Reckoning
which means any portion of a day whether
it's a few hours or an hour uh it counts
as a whole day uh so by looking at this
you also need to take into consideration
that um the scribes and the Pharisees
and Sadducees were always looking for
something to contradict and there's no
contradiction about Jesus being
resurrected on the third day now it says
in 1 Corinthians chapter 15: 3 and 4 uh
for I delivered unto you first of all
that which I also receive how that
Christ died for our sins according to
the scriptures and that he was buried
and that he rose again the third day
according to the scriptures so yes the
scriptures declare that he did fulfill
Jesus did fulfill exactly what he said
how was it done well when you take into
consideration the following scripture uh
that I'm going to read in Luke 23 we
will take a look at that Luke 23
beginning in verse 50 and behold there
was a man named Joseph a counselor and
he was a good man and a just the same
had not consented to the counsel and
deed of them he was of ARA a city of the
Jews who was who also himself waited for
the kingdom of God this man went to
pilate and begged the body of Jesus and
he took it down and wrapped it in linen
and laid it in a Sepulcher that was hued
in stone where wherein never a man
before was laid Luke 23:54 and that day
was the preparation that means the sixth
day and it says and the Sabbath Drew on
the Sabbath DW on so Friday is the
preparation day and the Sabbath dwan the
seventh day Saturday was coming this is
what the scriptures say now Luke 23:55
and the women also which came with him
for G From Galilee followed after and
beheld the Sepulcher how his body was
laate and they returned and prepared
spices and ointments and rested the
Sabbath day according to the Commandment
so we have the preparation day Friday uh
a portion of that day and Jesus was put
in the Tomb uh the Sabbath starts um and
it's night time and then you have the
Sabbath part of the day and then you
have the the the night and then Sunday
the first day Jesus is resurrected so
Jesus a portion of each day uh was in
the Tomb and according to Jewish
Reckoning that equals to 3 days um you
know uh there are some things that we
could continue looking at um but time is
in essence here this is called inclusive
Reckoning any part of the day counts as
a day uh for example I have here a
document
from um the
US government where it says um for non
immigrant Pur purposes any traditional
24-hour period in which a national
spends even one hour in the United
States is considered by USCIS to be one
day if you're one day in the U if you're
one hour in the US that's considered a
day and so you have some Modern aspects
of this still that spills into society
as well very good thank you very much uh
we talked about that inclusive Reckoning
you said huh yes all right now we are
going going to return to pastor rafy
with our next question and we want to
thank the person who sent in the text
does God come with Jesus at the second
coming what does the Bible say James
raffy that is an excellent question yes
the father is with Jesus at the second
coming we know this because of what the
Bible tells us for example Matthew
chapter 16 and verse 27 let's just read
the text Matthew 16: 27 for the son of
man shall come in the glory of the
father with his angels and then shall he
reward every man according to his work
so we know Jesus is coming with his
angels that's what the text says but it
also says he's coming with in the glory
of his father so that's Matthew
16:27 now this is what Jesus said to the
Jewish leaders who rejected him as
Messiah regarding his return this text
is found in Matthew 26 and verse 64
Jesus said unto him thou Hast said said
nevertheless I say unto you and this
talking to the high priest Hereafter you
shall see the son of man sitting on the
right hand of power and coming in the
Clouds Of Heaven he's speaking of his
second coming here in Matthew 26 and
verse 64 and he says when he comes the
second time you're going to see me
sitting on the right hand of power now
the Bible tells us that Jesus sits on
the right hand of the Throne of God so
the right hand of power and the right
hand of the Throne of God would be the
same thing and that's found in Hebrews
12 2 notice what it says looking under
Jesus the author and finisher of of our
faith who for the joy that was set
before him endured the cross despising
the shame and is set down at the right
hand of the Throne of God so definitely
the right hand of power is the right
hand of the Throne of God now there's
another scripture that covers this very
clearly and it's found in the Book of
Revelation actually it's Revelation 6:
14 to1 17 and just to give you the
context of this this is also a picture
of the second coming of Jesus Christ and
in this picture when Jesus is coming
there's the kings of the earth and the
great men and the and the and the and
the rich and the poor they all Run for
the Rocks they want to be hidden in the
caves and the rocks and the dens of the
mountains and they say as they're
running to the Rocks they say this again
is revelation 6:14 to1 17 they say hide
us fall on us and hide us from the face
of him that sits on the throne and from
the Wrath of the lamb for the great day
of his wrath is coming who shall be able
to stand so there's two people they want
to be hidden from the lamb right
obviously and also the face of him who
sits on the throne and that would be of
course God and we we know that when we
compare Revelation 614 to17 with
Revelation 5 verse1 God sits on the
throne there Revelation uh 7:10 also
clarifies who's sitting on the throne
because it says in Revelation 7:10 that
the great multitude of the redeemed CED
with a loud voice saying salvation to
our god which sits upon the throne and
unto the lamb so God is omnipresent
anyway why would we think that he
wouldn't be with Jesus if he's
omnipresent he can be in all places at
all times so just just to summarize we
know that Christ is coming with power
and great glory and he's coming with his
own glory and with the glory of the
father amen thank you very much Pastor
rafy we move on to the next question
thank you Estephanie for your email and
Pastor moriconi the question is the
Bible States in nahm 1 n that sin will
not rise up a second time why did Sin
rise in the first place why is there so
much suffering just to demonstrate that
sin is
detrimental good question well that is a
good question Stephanie that's an
important question too many people ask
that question why was sin permitted you
know God knows the end from the
beginning and uh in 2 Thessalonians
chapter 2:7 it says that the the
lawlessness our sin is is a mystery so
there's no explanation for it if we try
to explain it then it would be giving an
excuse for it so we can't do that
Ezekiel 28: 14 and 15 and it's speaking
of Lucifer it says Thou Art the anointed
cherub that
coverthe so thou was upon the holy
mountain of God thou Hast walked up and
down in the midst of the stones of fire
that thou was perfect in thy ways from
the day that thou was created till
iniquity was found in thee so God
created a perfect being Lucifer he was a
covering cherub that stood in the
presence of God in verse 17 says thine
heart was lifted up because of thy
Beauty thou Hast corrupted thy wisdom by
reason of thy righteous I mean by thy
reason of thy brightness I will cast
thee to the ground I will lay thee
before kings that they may behold thee
so somehow again we don't have a reason
or excuse but it says thine heart was
lifted up meaning he became proud of his
Beauty and thou Hast corrupted thy
wisdom by reason of thy brightness again
it was his own choice that he let his
wisdom and Beauty go to his head in
Matthew chap 13: 24-3 we see Jesus
giving a parable Regarding why tears
were growing up Amongst the Wheat
and he said an enemy has done this so
God sees the end from the beginning if
while he's creating a being or person
with the ability to choose whether they
will serve him or not and he sees in the
future that they're going to choose to
go against him if he decided hey I don't
think I'm going to create that person
what kind of God would he be in your
eyes he he is love and he created beings
with the ability to love to choose
what's the ability to choose when we see
how much he loves us then we respond
with love back to him and to others in 1
John 4:19 it says that we love him
because he first loved us so our our
love is um or his love makes a response
from us to love him back so by looking
at Jesus and his love for us so as far
as why sin was permitted it was or um
came about was because of uh the choice
of mankind or Lucifer
himself thank you very much Pastor modon
and thank you Stephanie for sending in
your question we received also an email
with the following question and I'm
addressing this question to John Den
okay is Jesus with the dying in their
final moments of life is there a moment
when the dying can accept Jesus Christ
as his or her Lord and Savior would you
please answer that question that came
through email well thank you for that
question this is a very important
questional and um I don't know what it
led you to write this question there is
a possibility that someone that is dying
can ask the Lord and to have mercy upon
them and forgive them for their sins
seems like a realization that wasted
time wasted life and now is at the
moment uh when the person is uh about to
die that the person then
understands uh the danger they are in
and appeal to God and His Mercy now God
looks at the heart he sees the sincerity
of the person and that person can be
received you have an example of that at
the cross when Jesus Christ is dying
there's a one of the two thieves now
notice one uh not not both uh said to
Jesus Remember Me When you um come into
your kingdom and Jesus said uh promises
him that he will be with him in Paradise
so there is apparently a moment when
that exact moment is God knows but I
would not
place um that in in the mind to say I'm
going to wait till I'm in my death bed
right to ask the Lord to forgive me and
then I will make it to Heaven no that is
a dangerous dangerous idea and um may
not work out for you because what
happens is that as we live our lives the
Lord is the appealing appealing to us
every I will say constantly to to repent
and give our hearts to him the more we
resist the harder our heart becomes and
it uh be can become so callous that we
reject the Holy Spirit and we will not
have that opportunity however let's look
at some scriptures really quick here
Hebrews 13:5 let your conduct be without
covetousness but content be content with
such things as ye have for he himself
has said I will never leave you no
forsake you so God promises to be with
us even to the very last moment of our
life Matthew 28 uh verse 20 says uh I
Jesus says I will be with you always
even to the End of the Age amen uh Psalm
23:4 yay though I walk through the
valley of the shadow of death I will
fear no evil for you are with me your
rod and your staff they comfort me and
yes the presence of the Lord Lord uh
with us his rod in his staff Comfort us
even to the very last moment of our
lives so yes if your question is uh if
somebody is dying is the Lord there with
him yes every moment of Our Lives Jesus
is with us and it's appealing to us to
draw close to him appealing to us to
repent and we have great opportunity to
do so but let's not wait till the very
last minute of Our Lives because I have
heard of people dying instantly they
don't even have a moment to even think
and they just cease to exist so don't
plan on that plan on giving your heart
to the Lord Jesus Christ right now amen
yes today is the day of salvation today
is the day of salvation that's right
praise God and you know In Heaven There
Will Be many surprises right many
surprises so praise God well we would
like to hear from you uh family at home
I'd like to share the contact
information because um as we discuss
these questions perhaps your questions
has surfaced to your memory and now it's
your opportunity to send it via email
Bible QA 3abn.org
Tex not only your comments but also your
questions this is your class so 618 228
3975 that number again is 618 228
3975 now we continue with James raferty
and this is the question I think Rick
from Canada who wrote the text send in
the text and Pastor refy gets the honor
of answering this question can you
explain Hebrews 87
7-13 Hebrews 8 7-13 thank you Rick great
question this is actually talking about
the New Covenant or the Everlasting
Covenant the covenant made with Abraham
in the Old Testament and the Covenant
that is uh ratified by Jesus and his
death on the cross and he's contrasting
here in Hebrews 8 he's contrasting this
uh Covenant with the old Covenant he
begins in verse 7 you asked about verses
7 through 13 and he says but now we have
a obtained the more ex he has obtained
the more excellent Ministry speaking of
Christ by how much more he is also the
mediator of a better Covenant which was
established upon better promises and so
we have a contrast here developing this
this is a better Covenant the the
Everlasting Covenant the first covenant
made with Abraham and this this Covenant
ratified by Christ is a better Covenant
and Galatians 4 actually talks about the
two covenants and illustrates them in
Abraham's experience the old Covenant
with his relationship with Hagar and the
New Covenant with his relationship with
Sarah and so you've got the same person
in the Old Testament experiencing both
covenants just to tell us that the the
the context here is not talking about a
time and a place like old Covenant is
Old Testament New Covenant is New
Testament it's talking about a
relationship and an experience where we
trust in God rather than trusting in
ourselves Abraham trusted in Hagar to
fulfill God's promise of a child later
he trusted in God's promise alone alone
according to Romans 4 to fulfill God's
promise of a child and then it goes on
to say for if the first Covenant had
been faultless then should no place have
been found for the second so the first
Covenant in the sense of the Sinai
Covenant God found fault with them verse
four the fault was that they said all
the Lord has said we will do and be
obedient and they weren't and they can't
be and we can't be and so the New
Covenant says behold the day has come
says the Lord verse 8 when I will make a
covenant with the house of Israel and
with the house of Judah of course this
is talking about spiritual Israel
according to Romans 2:24 and2 those who
are Abraham's are in Christ are
Abraham's seed according and HS
according to the promise and this is the
promise of the New Covenant this is the
Covenant I will make with them says the
Lord of hosts right uh not according to
that Covenant verse nine that I made
with their fathers in the day that I
took them by the hand to lead them out
of the land of Egypt because they
continu not in my Covenant they made bad
promises and I regarded them not says
the Lord this is the Covenant I'm going
to make I'm going to put my laws in
their mind and write them in their heart
the Ten Commandments in our minds and
hearts I'm going to be to them a God and
they're going to be to me a people
relationship they're going to not teach
every man his neighbor and every man his
brother saying know the Lord for all
will know me from the least to the
greatest that's Holy Spirit teaching and
unction according to First John chapter
2 and then verses 20 and 27 and then I
will be merciful to their
unrighteousness and their sins and
iniquities I will remember no more
remembering no more our sins and
iniquities is the Forgiveness of the New
Covenant and remember all of this is
done by Jesus by God it's his Covenant
his promises he fulfills them we believe
that amen amen Al righty then we are
moving to Indiana and we received a text
from Susan so thank you Susan for
sending taking the time to send in your
text and your question was what are the
holy ghost's duties in our lives and
this question is addressed to Pastor
moriconi what are the holy ghost's
duties in our lives well that's a good
question Susan thank you so much for
sending that in the importance of the
holy spirit that that's to concentrate
on what the holy spirit's job is that's
you know John Chapter 14 verse 26 you
know Jesus was getting ready to leave
here and he was promising the disciples
another comforter so here it says but
the comforter which is the Holy Ghost
whom the father will send in my name he
shall teach you all things there's one
of his duties
and bring all things to your remembrance
if you're like me I don't have a very
good memory so what a blessing to have
the Holy Spirit bring us to our
remembrance and uh whatsoever I have
said unto you and then John chap 16
verse 7-14 it says nevertheless I tell
you the truth it is expedient for you
that I go away for if I go not away the
comforter will not come unto you you
know that has more to do with they were
so concentrated on Jesus being here that
they wouldn't really pay attention to
the Holy Spirit if he was to hang around
in other words they they just always
look to Jesus whereas the Holy Spirit he
could be with each one of them
individually anywhere they were so in
that context of what that's saying there
so I'll read that again nevertheless I
tell you the truth it is expedient for
you that I go away for if I go not away
the comforter will not come unto you but
if I depart I will send him unto you in
other words you'll pay more attention to
him and in verse 8 and when he when he
has come he will reprove here's some
more duties of him he will reprove the
world of sin and righteousness and
Judgment of this is verse n of sin
because they believe not on me of
righteousness because I go to my father
and ye see me no more of judgment
because the prince of this world is
judged and verse 12 I have many things
to say to you but you cannot bear them
now so Jesus wanted to share a whole
bunch of stuff but they just weren't
prepared weren't ready in verse 13 how
be it when he the spirit of Truth has
come here's what he's going to the
duties of the Holy Spirit he will guide
you into all Truth for he shall not
speak of himself but whatsoever he shall
hear that shall he speak and he will
show you the things to come these are
all his duties he shall glorify me now
Jesus is talking about the holy spirit's
going to glor glorify Jesus for he shall
receive of mine and shall show it unto
you so what a blessing that we have the
Holy Spirit that can do all of these
things that we won't want to take him
for granted we should always pray and
ask the Lord to bless us when we open
his word and the main thing too is to
hear him and to listen to him obey him
thank you for again for that
question amen amen thank you very much
Pastor moriconi you know it's wonderful
when we can share uh the links to these
programs in social media because the
reach is outstanding but we want to
thank our viewers in South Africa um
sand thank you for sending your email in
and we're going to address this question
we're going to pass it on to John deny
and your question is s says First Kings
21:29 says have you noticed how Ahab has
humbled himself before me because he has
humbled himself I will not bring this
disaster in his day but I will bring it
on his house in the days of his son why
does God show Mercy to the one who is
guilty and knows what they have done yet
reserves a punishment for the children
who might not even know why they are
being punished thank you
Sanda that's a very good question and as
we look at it uh it seems unfair if this
were the case but notice that it says
there like you read that Ahab humbled
himself in humbling himself he confessed
his sins to God and God was able to
forgive him then that eliminates his
guilt you see because it says in 1 John
chapter 1 ver9 if we confess our sins he
is faithful and just to forgive us our
sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness but your question is why
would he show Mercy to this guy and then
visit punishment on the children even
though they may not know why they are
punished
um they might know why they are being
punished but let's go ahead and take
take a look at the principle that God
brings to us in Jeremiah 13 and then
we'll go to um Ezekiel chapter 18 having
time Jeremiah 137 and 8 it says the
instant I speak concerning a nation and
concerning a kingdom to pluck it up to
pull down and to destroy it this would
include people if that Nation against
whom I have spoken turns from from its
evil way I will relent of the disaster
that I thought to bring upon it in the
same way in this scripture that you read
if the children do not follow uh evil
then God would not punish them with evil
let's go ahead and see what happened to
ahab's son notice it says in First Kings
chapter 22 verse 40 so Ahab slept with
his fathers and ahaziah his son reigned
in his dead now remember ahaziah was
supposed to be visited with punishment
if he did Evil uh but if he lived a
righteous life God will not visit him
with evil notice what it says remember
what we read in Jeremiah 13 if God says
if a nation if I speak concerning a
nation uh to do to them according to
their sins and they turn away I will not
visit them with punishment so notice uh
ahaziah ahab's son what did he do uh
First Kings 22:51
ahaziah the son of Ahab began to Reign
Over Israel in Samaria the 17th year of
Jehoshaphat king of Judah and reigned
two years of Israel and he did evil in
the sight of the Lord and walked in the
way of his father and in the way of his
mother and in the way of jeroboam the
son of nebat who made Israel to sin for
he served Baal and worshiped him and
provoked to anger the Lord God of Israel
according to all that his father had
done so we see here that ahiah
actually uh did evil in the sight of the
Lord and so he will be visited with
punishment and he there's no apparent um
confession there's no apparent uh
returning Away From Evil now Ezekiel 18
I move there quickly beginning of verse
14 it says if however a father he begets
a son who sees all the sins which his
father has done and considers but does
not do likewise who has not eaten on the
mountains nor lifted his eyes to the
idols of the House of Israel nor defiled
his neighbor's wife uh has not oppressed
anyone nor withheld The Pledge nor
robbed by violence but has given his
bread to the hungry and covered the
naked clothing who has withdrawn his
hand from the poor and not received
Usery or increase but has executed my
judgments and walked my statutes he
shall not die for the iniquity of his
father he shall live uh verse 20 of
Ezekiel 18:28 the soul who sins shall
die the son shall not bear the guilt of
the father nor the father bear the guilt
of the son the righteousness of the
righteous shall be upon himself and the
wickedness of the wicked shall be upon
himself so the Lord treats each person
according to the way he has lived thank
you thank you Dynamic now we're going to
Delaware thank you for your text Estel
now Pastor rafy the question is the
Bible refers to the body of Christ and
the bride of Christ are these the same
what scriptures can I look at to better
understand what these terms mean Estelle
needs to know thank you Estelle that's a
great question and I'm just going to
immediately go to the scriptures that
you can look at and then we'll go back
and take a look at a few of the details
the first scripture you want to look at
to identify the bride of Christ is going
to be Revelation chap 21 and you want to
look at verses 9-14 Revelation 21: 9-14
that will describe the bride of Christ
then then you want to look at in
relationship to the body of Christ you
want to look at several scriptures the
first one is found in Colossians
1:8 the second one is found in Romans 12
4-5 and then you want to look at 1
Corinthians chapter 12 the whole chapter
is really good on the body of Christ but
you can specifically look at verses 20
excuse me 12- 27 so 1 Corinthians 12
12-27 Romans 12: 4 and 5 Colossians
1:8 and then for the bride of Christ
Revelation 21: 9-14 let's go back and
just take a look in the time we have
remaining at some of the details of
these verses there is a difference
between the bride of Christ and the and
the body of Christ the bride of Christ
is described in Revelation CH 21 in
these words and there came unto me one
of the Seven Angels which had the seven
vials full of the seven last plagues and
he talked with me saying come hither and
I will show you the bride the Lamb's
wife and he carried me away in the
spirit to a great and high mountain and
showed me the great City the holy
Jerusalem descending Out of Heaven from
God having the glory of God and her
light was like a stone most precious
even a jasper stone clear as Crystal she
had a great high wall 12 gates and 12
angels with the names of the 12 tribes
written there and then uh she had 12
foundations with the name of the
Apostles of the Lamb written there so
the New Jerusalem City city is
identified in Revelation chap 21 as the
bride of Christ and of course God's
people will all be part of that City and
then we're told in relationship to the
other Bible verses that the body of
Christ is his church his people
specifically and the terminology is used
because God is describing his church as
a body that he utiliz on planet Earth to
reach the world with the gospel so some
of us are mouth and ears and eyes and
feet and hands all of the different
gifts are given to the body the Church
of Christ to preach the gospel and share
the gospel with the world so that all
who hear and receive Jesus Christ can be
part of the redeemed and end up in that
New Jerusalem city which is the bride of
Christ so look at the verses that we've
uh mentioned and you'll see the
difference there between the bride of
Christ and the body of Christ and how
they both come together in the New
Jerusalem City excellent thank you so
much Pastor rafy we are moving on to
pastor moriconi Pastor moriconi Ismael
from Florida sent in an email and he has
this question had Lucifer Fallen before
the creation of Eden if no please
explain the first part of Ezekiel
Ezekiel
28:13 yeah that is a good question
Ismail and um let's go ahead and read
that first part of U Ezekiel 28:13
says Thou Hast been in Eden the Garden
of God every precious stone was thy
covering now when we drop down to verse
14 it says Thou Art the anointed cherub
that
coverthe set thee so thou was upon the
holy mountain of God thou Hast walked up
and down in the midst of the stones of
fire verse 15 thou was perfect in thy
ways from the day that thou was created
till iniquity was found in thee verse 16
by the multitude of thy merchandise they
have filled the midst of thee with
violence and thou Hast sinned therefore
I will cast thee as profane out of the
Mountain of God and I will destroy thee
Oh covering chb from the midst of the
stones of
fire as far as the word Eden the Hebrew
meaning for the word Eden it actually
means place of pleasure that's the
actual meaning so the Holy Mountain of
God represents against the seat of God's
government this is where Lucifer was he
was in the Holy uh Mountain of God God's
government or Heaven
itself the presence of God is often
presented as an environment of color and
fire you can see that in Revelation 4
3-5 and Revelation 12
7-9 it says and there was war in heaven
Michael and his angels fought against
the Dragon and the dragon fought against
his angels and prevailed not they lost
the dragon and his Angel neither was
their place found anymore in heaven and
the Great Dragon was cast out that old
serpent called the devil and Satan which
deceiveth the whole world so he was cast
out into this Earth and his angels were
cast out with him and Isaiah 1412 says
the same thing how art thou fallen from
Heaven oh Lucifer son of the morning how
art thou cut down to the ground which
did weaken the Nations so the takeaway
from this is that Lucifer he was a
perfect created being in heaven he chose
to let his Beauty and his wisdom go to
his head that's a pun he became as you
put it Ismail fallen so he was Fallen at
that point and if we look at Eden as a
place of pleasure and God having a
garden in heaven or places of pleasure
in heaven we can see that we can say
that Lucifer fell before God made a
garden called Eden here on this Earth or
place of pleasure in the Hebrew meaning
so we see the same when it comes to
making a sanctuary here on Earth it was
a replica of the sanctuary in heaven so
in heaven we can believe that there's
places of pleasure or Gardens of Eden we
could and then God makes a little one
here on this Earth for his people there
we can look at it from that angle so
remember the Hebrews 85 it says you know
he's talking to Moses there God says who
serve unto the example and Shadow of
heavenly things when he made the
sanctuary here on this Earth there was
one in
heaven and so Moses was admonished to
make the Tabernacle for see saith he
thou make all things according to the
pattern showed thee in the mount so it
would go along with that Satan was up in
heaven he fell you know got proud of his
own Beauty and his own intellect and
fell and then uh so that's when it's
talking about him being in Eden in
heaven I look at it from that angle and
of course he did come to this earth and
was in this earth Eden but he had fallen
by that point because that's when he was
cast to this
earth all right well thank you again for
that question Ismail yes thank you
Ismail and thank you everyone who have
sent in their questions and comments and
quickly John Deni would you please
answer this question for Melinda she's
from Michigan and she's sending a text
on the day of atonement in Leviticus the
Israelites were to practice self-denial
what did that look like then and how do
we apply it
today Melinda I am very glad that you
asked this question it's a very solemn
question to consider when we understand
the day of atonement for the people of
Israel and that was a shadow of the true
day of atonement
uh time of atonement that began in 1844
we understand from Daniel chapter 8 and
Daniel chapter 9 that the eventually the
sanctuary will be cleansed we don't have
time to uh share all of that but let's
look at Leviticus chapter
23 beginning in verse 26 and the Lord
spoke to Moses saying also on the 10th
day 10th day of this month shall be the
day of atonement it shall be a holy
convocation for you you shall afflict
your souls that's number one the people
of Israel were to afflict their souls
and offer an offering made by fire to
the Lord and you shall do no work on
that same day for it is the day of
atonement to make atonement for you
before the Lord your God for any person
who is not Afflicted in Soul on that
same day shall be cut off from his
people a very very serious day all work
was to stop it was a time when
reconciliation was being made for God's
children uh so separating themselves
from work and things that would distract
them from what was going on in the most
holy place in the Earthly Tabernacle the
it was a time of fasting a time of
prayer because the high priest was in
the most holy place which he only went
once a year to do this now notice what
what it says here uh in verse 29 for any
person we read that who is not Afflicted
in so on that same day shall be caught
up from his people everyone was supposed
to be involved in this you shall do no
manner of work it shall be a statue
forever throughout your Generations in
all your dwellings it shall be to you a
Sabbath of solemn rest and you shall
afflict your souls on the ninth ninth
day of the month at evening from evening
to evening you shall celebrate your
Sabbath now this was a very solemn day
uh things were going on in the most holy
place to cleanse the people from the
sins they had confessed throughout the
whole year just like that Jesus is in
the most holy place in heaven now is not
a shadow now is the real day of
atonement the real time of atonment from
the 18 October 22nd 1844 we have
information on that that you can order
from 3abn to understand this fully what
are we to be doing today we should be
afflicting our souls we should be
separating our elv from things that
would distract us from the solemn day of
atonement uh so if there's anything that
distracts you from being in close
relationship with the Lord and distract
you from a prayer life put that away
Jesus Christ is ministering in the most
holy place in heaven and we need to also
consider the things we eat because they
were fasting on the on that day because
of the great work that was being done
for them by the high priest we need to
consider what we are putting into our
bodies that may be distraction for our
health and our spiritual life amen thank
you very much definitely a lot of
information that we can continue to look
into well we're going to take a break
right now don't walk away from the
television or don't change the channel
we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org Q&A for answers from God's
word well I just want to thank you for
joining us joining your class Bible Q&A
uh Pastor rery do you have a quick
goodbye message for our viewers just a
New Covenant it's really all about God's
power God relationship God's spirit
God's forgiveness and God's law in our
hearts and in our minds amen amen Pastor
moriconi well thank you again for all
those good questions you guys are Fant
fantastic out there giving us all these
questions and we have the privilege to
look them up and give you the answers
thank you amen and John deny what are
your Waits we are in the great day of
atonement Jesus Christ our high priest
is in the most holy place in heaven
doing a great and important work to
cleanse us from our sin we should be
confessing our sin separating ourselves
from Evil and work in harmony with
what's going on in the most holy place
in heaven amen amen well when I used to
teach I used to learn a lot from my
students and so it's beautiful to hear
your Curiosities your questions remember
there's no question to simple or no
question too big uh God is the answer
for everything and God has given us his
word to uh study and receive his answers
I want to invite you for the next
edition of The Bible Q&A program right
here at 3abn thank you so much may the
Lord guide you as you study his word see
you next time name
[Music]